[Music]
Clean Slate is an initiative that we're
starting and I ask that you consider
joining us if you go to my Instagram or
my Twitter right now everything is gone
there needs to be a change of course
before we get to the point that there's
no turning back a lot of the things that
we discuss the artificial machine would
tell you you don't want to see it I
don't agree I'm going to see you on the
22nd Gerald apologizes apologetics it
doesn't mean that all right mug Club hey
everybody thank you for joining us for
Gerald apologizes apologetics it doesn't
quite mean what they say that it means I
understand that they just do that to
kind of uh I don't know Punk me because
we spent all this money on the intros
for everybody else but not for me that's
fine that's fine I'll get over it I'll
be okay don't worry about me I uh I had
an interesting conversation back in June
with uh Our Guest today and it it was
very quick on the show and we started
talking about demons and the mark of the
beast and I was like H that that's
that's escy I'm very interested in that
and so Alex Jones I I thought I'd come
down here and hang out in your world and
we could continue our conversation I
think it literally lasted maybe 60
seconds on air and we didn't really get
into it a whole Captain Morgan you are
now promoted to Admiral Morgan Admiral
Morgan sitting in this chair is a little
weird I mean it's it's like huh this is
this kind of a nice place I like it I've
seen this on on the air I love you in
Steven's studio and you got to get step
back down here sometimes I know one of
these days we're going to get him in the
car or maybe a little we've done shows
out on the street together but never in
the studio I remember that you said
something about Bumpus I believe
being actually did throw up it was so
gross so is it just the smell of that
yeah just the smell of it or the thought
and I was extremely hung over that day
too so let's not lie no no I mean I'm a
lay person when it comes to in of the
world type stuff but I did go to a lot
of church a lot of Sunday school I have
read the Bible quite a bit I know
there's massive amounts of study I you
could have five degrees in it never know
half of it but my
grandfather my mother's father was
really heavily into it studied the Bible
Daniel and Ezekiel and and and
Revelation pretty much much like 5 hours
a day he was really smart and and and a
quite a historian he'd been a successful
inventor right a lot of other things but
uh last 20 years of his life he's
dedicated to studying the Bible I
remember him like breaking down the New
World Order and Global government they'd
have a computer and that would control
everybody and you'd have to do what they
said or you wouldn't get the mark he
would always explain you don't just take
it and then it's because you've taken it
that you're going to go to hell it's
that taking it you have to submit and
worship and follow the whole system so
he would basically rant kind of like
Alex Jones almost he was my grandfather
he even looked like me uh just about
this all the time and I would you know
come and visit him in the Summers and
then and then I'm I moved down there
when I was a senior in high school
started hanging out with him and my
grandmother almost every week what what
years roughly what decade was this uh I
was I graduated out of high school in '
92 okay and so I moved here like in
1991 and so my grandparents lived here
yeah and he was just really big into
eschatology and so that that I mean I
heard a lot from him well the church
used to be really big into it and that's
why I was really asking that because
back in the 1980s I mean there was a lot
of fire and brimstone preaching and a
part of that was telling the end of the
story so let me just tell the the the
guys listening and gals right now we're
we're talking about the end times so
esqu is kind of the study of the end
times and just so you understand what
that is if Genesis is kind of telling
the beginning of the story which it
obviously is uh Revelation and some of
the prophetic literature leading up to
that is really telling you how things
come to an end and some of the things
that Alex just said would have just been
in the 1960s 1950s 40s 1800s you're
crazy there's no way any of that stuff
could happen but obviously we see a lot
of it happening today and so people are
very interested it's apocalyptic anytime
you see a History Channel show that
talks about the apocalypse or something
like that people tune in because they're
like oh there's something that draws us
into to want to know a little bit more
and this subject is debated quite a bit
right we were talking just a second ago
about mid-trip pre-trip post-trip no
trip whatever there are a lot of
different reasons for you to care about
this right we'll dive into just a very
basic framew work of what we're talking
about and then we're going to talk about
specific segments specifically 666 the
mark of the beast how that's being
potentially implemented today and how uh
how you can make sure that you don't
accidentally do that you can't that's
the whole the the kind of the trick to
it you can't accidentally take the mark
of the beast but we're going to hit a
few more points maybe something that
most people don't know is that for every
prophecy on the first coming of Christ
which that is the Messiah that is for
the Jews that's it right they were
waiting for and looking for and
desperately hoping for messiah to come
for every prophecy in the Bible about
messiah's first coming there are roughly
eight concerning the second coming
there's eight more than the first coming
right so it's multiple times more
mentioned in the Bible and a lot of
people don't really take a lot of time
to understand those prophecies or to
really kind of think through it they do
take time to go Revelation tough to
understand Revelation is difficult
because there's there's all this imagery
that's being used and there's all this
flowery language that I don't really
understand and we'll get into why some
Christians have a bit of a problem with
that but it's important important for
you to know because God spent about
eight times the time speaking about the
second coming than he did the first
coming and obviously the first one was a
big deal because it kind of Saved people
without the first coming the second
coming doesn't really quite matter that
much because we would all be under
judgment and I wouldn't want to be
around for that anyway but I guess my my
big question Alex is why what made you
start so you talked about it a little
bit was your grandfather you said yes uh
so other than that was there any
influence or was it just your
grandfather's influence talking about
kind of eschatology that made you dive
into it a little bit well I want to 100%
clear I mean the the new world order has
brought us the end times and has proven
the Bible's right so that's why I've got
way more interested I mean growing up we
went to church on Sundays and then we
would have Bible studies a lot of times
at the house on Sunday night but my
parents LED uh and and and I could watch
if I wanted to and hang out there if I
wanted to be like 20 people there but
usually there'd be some other kids we
run around outside uh and we went to you
know uh Church on Wednesdays uh and we
went to a Evangelical style you know a
pretty big church and and so I was just
growing up with this as a background and
so it's kind of the back of your head
yeah and then my grandfather uh once I
moved to Austin when I was in college
and and then you have my job and already
on air for a lot of years he he died
about 12 years ago my grandmother about
five years ago he was just constantly
saying watch this is all going to be
fulfilled and he would get really upset
when he'd see these preachers on TV
setting a date he would say those people
are deceived by setting a date them when
it doesn't happen that's going to make
people fall away that's a tool of the
devil and he was just really uh he said
you know comes like a thief in the night
no man knoweth is Christ to the hour of
the return and so then I've seen the
left use that when the these preachers
get a bunch of attention saying it's
this date for like a year that it
doesn't happen then they say oh the
Bible's disproven the Bible says no one
knows and if they tell you they know
that person's bad yeah exactly so it's
all there and so the older you get the
more you know you go this is incredible
like I get chills right now so I want to
be clear I'm not Mr preacher and I'm not
holier than thou uh I mean I don't tell
lies on purpose and I don't sell out to
evil but I mean I made the point about
being hung over that's probably why I
was throwing up I mean I've got my own
issues I'm not perfect I'm not on some
I'm not on some high horse so many
people are turned off by the church
because it's it's it's it's preaching a
water down Bible and it's it and it's
it's also just attacking people
individually instead of showing him the
big picture the devil's real God's real
you better pick a side and so people ask
why I'm so much in the end times is
it's here and it's all being fulfilled
and the globalists are fulfilling it and
saying the future is not human you will
merge the machines you will submit to
all our social credit scores our esgs
you'll be tracked in livetime uh the
Bible says everyone worldwide will see
the image of the Beast talking to them
at once they'll worship it that's
television Holograms right I mean it's
it's like there's no way johnop Patmos
2,000 years ago just made this up
there's no way Daniel just made it up or
Ezekiel and and it's just all congruent
proving itself proving itself proving
itself and so if someone doesn't have
the holy spirit of discernment they read
it's a bunch of gibberish but once you
actually are plus we're living in the
time you said something so important
I'll shut up for a minute Gerald and
that is in in the in in the 70s and 80s
I mean there I was not just going to our
church but I would also go with my
friends to their church and it was like
like there were all these movies and
films and people were really awake and
there's going to be a one world
government in the Beast system in
Brussels and a beast computer everywhere
it was everywhere and then once the '90s
and the 2000s and once it all started
coming true the preachers went whoa
because it's one thing to say the Bible
says it's coming and then it's kind of
like science fiction and really
interesting but now a lot of the
preachers are like whoa I'm not going to
scare the hell out of people which is
actually we should be celebrating and
going my gosh our God is real this is a
warning God gave us free will but God
also gave us a cheat sheet yeah and and
so like hey kids I want you to pass the
test here kind of here's the so if you
pay attention you will and so this is a
big deal and this is 100% real and then
I think about the experience
I had in Dallas particularly and then
coming to Austin and then being around
Hollywood which never tried to be in but
it wanted me to be in it and it it and
it was Satanism luciferianism sex
parties the whole nine yards I never got
into rituals but I was picked up by
chicks repeatedly trying to recruit me
into things in Dallas and a decade later
in Hollywood Austin's more new Agy not a
lot of that here uh but but that's
almost more a more creepy form of it so
so I've really you know I never fell
away said I denounced God and God as a
real I'm an atheist but I mean I was in
points in my life I wasn't taking drugs
really but I was drinking and a lot of
women and yeah you know and on a power
trip and really prideful about how you
know I was and I'd say I got I'd say I
was kind of corrupt let's say maybe 14
to about 20 uh and then I kind of
rediscovered God and then the Holy
Spirit much more stronger than when I
was saved when I was about 10 and and
then literally God started talking to me
and showing me things and like and I
would have dreams that came true and all
these things and I just now I get
stronger and stronger and stronger to
where and you talk about spiritual
warfare we'll get into it at this point
that's all we've I mean that is you have
Christ you have Jesus you have a faith
in that you are protected but then the
Devil comes after people that you love
who aren't in God that's why you've got
to get them into the Holy Spirit or the
devil's going to chew up your family in
front of you so that's what people
better understand this is more important
than guns in your gun cabinet or tble
food or water is getting your heart and
soul ready because believe me folks
without God you you won't be able to
withstand Satan this is going to be
hardcore no flesh will be spared if God
doesn't intervene right and and I want
to bring something back up that you said
and I'll get to that in just a second
what you just said no flesh will be
spared unless God intervenes there's
some great quotes for us that that
really help us in Scripture that say
that unless the unless the Lord guards
the city The Watchman watches in vain
like it doesn't matter you can be as
prepared as you want to be but if God is
not watching over the city it really
doesn't matter right it's it's a bigger
picture than this but churches did get
away from this and I think maybe because
they started seeing people kind of
practice this escapism right so instead
of focusing on being productive here and
now right what am I supposed to do today
what am I supposed to do in the next 5
years of my life if by chance the Lord
allows me to have those they started
looking kind of into the future and they
were so Heavenly minded that they were
no earthly good is what my pastors would
say every once in a while but churches
got away from preaching about Revelation
and Daniel and some other topics that
are very very interesting and very
important topics because it basically
gives you the opportunity to point at
scripture and go God called that right
in Ezekiel when it talks about the dry
bones and the the nation of Israel
coming back like that's a that's
something that has to happen for the
Rapture to happen for the tribulation to
happen it talks about them having a
temple and and having sacrifices and
then having the Abomination that causes
desolation set up well if Israel isn't a
country if Israel doesn't have the Land
There is no Temple right there is no
Temple right now but it's impossible
unless they're there well until 1948
that was impossible until modern
television was invented it was
impossible for us to all watch the two
witnesses at the Wailing Wall and it
says that when those guys are killed
because they've tormented people for
this period of time just by speaking the
truth and withholding rign to basically
say guys you have to listen let me get
your attention no rain let me get your
attention listen to God loves you he
wants to save you they rejoice and the
entire world watches them die and then
they exchange gifts like it's Christmas
and then they're brought back to life
and it freaks everybody out obviously if
somebody was brought back to life after
3 days laying on the ground and we've
been celebrating their death it'd be a
little weird I'd kind of get freaked out
too I get it I understand but none of
that technologically was even possible
and so when churches don't get into this
I think they're doing a bit of a
disservice to their congregations
because it it's almost think about what
we have now with kind of the cancel
culture right we're obviously both very
familiar with how that works in our
society you create a vacuum you start to
create a vacuum where people go okay
well you're not talking about this so
I'm going to go listen to 15 or 16 or 20
other people over here talking about it
and I may not be grabbing good
information right so when you start
cancelling people in our industry you
start pushing them off into the fringes
you can't easily point out the people
who are absolutely out of their minds
and go you know what don't listen to
that guy he's never been right before
the the the end of the world has never
come he's predicted it 17 times and
people go yeah you're right I can see
that I can see that this person's not
correct and not a reliable person to
judge uh or or to listen to to kind of
Judge whether the world is actually
coming to an end or not and it actually
does a disservice to people so I think
the church has done a bad job with that
let me let me just lay a little bit of
groundwork here it's important that you
understand this it is not important that
you debate this to the death with other
believers people tend to get into these
things and go you know what I am a new
King James Bible person or a King James
Bible person and there are no other
translations that absolutely are the
word of God and you're a heretic and
you're going to hell if you read the NIV
right they tend to kind of draw these
lines where we shouldn't we God judges
the heart not and Christ always the
Pharisees up there praying in public he
said no you need to pray in private it's
about you and God and I just want to be
clear with people this isn't about even
The Messengers here the devil is 100%
real the operating system of the of the
New World Order in the UN is
luciferianism they've got a lucious
Lucifer trust that runs the prayer
Chapel at in in New York at the UN I've
had these people try to recruit me and
some of it wasn't just in high school or
then later when I was in Hollywood some
it it it's happened since then were very
well-known household names said hey we
want you to go to this event in raichi
ofc or this event in Switzerland and and
it's new AG but we're Lucifer is not
really bad we're going to call in
Lucifer to fix the problems so I mean I
start thinking about how much of this we
Bohemian Grove I sneak in there I hear
there's this ritual they're doing a
ritual to the devil to under all these
Canaanite names it's like Ghostbusters
or something but for real and I look
over and the old men are are are more
intense than when I was in Holy Roller
churches you know because holy Ro church
is great people are like oh we love you
Lord these people are like I mean this
is real all I'm telling people is I
don't know if you've experienced stuff
like this but I'm telling you if you've
seen the stuff I've seen and I know God
put me in those places to see that so I
can now witness this to people you would
know God is real and I just keep
hammering that and and I but what you
said is critical there's a mix the whole
Rapture thing okay there's all this
scary stuff coming and the Bible's being
fulfilled so far people could see it's
starting to be fulfilled in the 70s and
80s technology so people go oh my gosh
this really is happening and then people
go oh but we're going to be raptured so
let's just go to sleep and stop looking
at it
and and so it's a mix half the folks or
whatever percentage it is a certain
percentage are scared and don't really
want to be bothered with it CU it is
awesome it is scary it is huge it's it's
it's it's Eternal it's a big decision
forever and the other ones are just like
Hey we're going to get rapture it's
going to be fine but if you really look
at the Bible I'm not going to debate
post you know mid uh or you know pre the
issue is right there we know there's a
big Awakening that of Christians later
that turn against the Antichrist and
then he starts killing everybody so so
we know there's going to be a group
that's awake before a group that doesn't
a huge Awakening during it and and you
correct me if I'm wrong you say it more
than I do and the Antichrist is just
slaughtering people and you once he goes
from nice guy to mean guy and we're
going to have the biggest Revival ever
seen in the middle of this it's just so
any way you slice it folks it's real
it's happening and people better get
serious yeah absolutely so let me let me
just lay this out for you and we're not
going to debate it I may ask Alex kind
of where he falls down on this stuff I I
really don't know it's very complex I
just know that God's real and the
devil's real it's about to get it's
about to get real messy one way or the
other right so look a lot of people
believe in what's called a Rapture and
if you're wondering what that is that's
a topic that's alluded to in scripture I
believe it's 1 Thessalonians 4 that
mentions being caught up to heaven kind
of in the twinkling of an eye and
there's a word that use their Harpo
right and that's that's where they talk
about this Rapture like this
instantaneous like catching up to be
with God and then at some point there is
a period of seven years that's called
either the time of Jacob's trouble I
think in Jeremiah or um the tribulation
right A lot of people look at the
tribulation and like oh it's a
seven-year period sort of the entire
tribulation is this seven-year period
but really the the really scary thing
Alex is that the Antichrist when he
comes to power is accepted with open
arms this person doesn't come in as a
conquering kind of uh uh dictator he he
show up in red pajamas right exactly
right he doesn't come in and say you
know you have to follow me people
willingly do that and before covid-19
hit most of you out there right now
probably thought like there 's no way
the world would just kind of jump in
lock step on something like this and
kind of give up their freedoms willingly
and shut down the entire world economy
and not ask really important questions
there's no way big Tech would like
completely censor genuine doctors asking
questions about this stuff there's no
way that would all happen everybody's
eyes got opened a little bit on how
quickly we fall apart how quickly we are
willing in times of trouble to welcome
in somebody who may not have our best
interest at heart to accept a great
delusion which the Bible says is
the the delusion was so strong it could
even deceive the elect what's the exact
quote that's exactly what it is you
nailed it sometimes you just got to
believe in yourself Alex oh I mean it's
I mean I've read this a 100 times but
you're trying to get the quote exactly
right no no I so I always Loosely quote
this thing like I've got some scripture
written down just to make sure that I
get it accurate but if you hear us talk
about it it's a loose quote acts 1711
was what I would always point to you to
don't believe Alex don't believe Gerald
go and study scripture and see if it is
true right that is that is what Paul
that everybody should do that one of my
favorite teachers Chuck mistler always
talked about that so do that make sure
you do it right all right so this seven
years three and a half really good years
then things switch in three and a half
really bad years and that's what we talk
about that's the tribulation that three
and a half years so this seven-year
period ends then there's a millennial
Kingdom which is a Thousand-Year rule of
Christ on Earth New Jerusalem the whole
thing and then at the end of that
there's what they call the white Throne
judgment new heaven new Earth right
that's the basic layout there are other
things that happen in there that I'm not
going to get into right now the devil
out for while again he does and I don't
know why like at the end of the Thousand
Years so Satan is bound and his his
they're thrown into the pit for a
thousand years and then he lets him out
for a little while and there's again
there's this additional battle that
happens and then there's free will it's
like okay you've had you've seen nothing
but pure goodness for a thousand years
now let's you want to be it's almost
like Adam and Eve all over again you get
to walk and talk with God essentially
right and now you have the opportunity
again to fall away and so that there's
this final battle I don't know why I
have no idea why God does that but I
understand that God is good and just and
I trust him a lot more than I trust
myself to figure this out but that's
true at the end of it so some people
believe that we're in the Millennium
right now and if so a lot of pastors
have said well if that's true then the
devil's chain is too long because he's
obviously on the March yeah well there's
that teaching that supposedly Titus
sacked Rome I mean sacked Jerusalem and
that was the end of the world then I
mean it doesn't have all the technology
the mark of the beast I I I just really
don't see that and it's not
understanding the ol of that discourse
right that the oliv that discourse and I
talked to my wife about this just a
little while ago by the way she loves
you she's a big fan I don't know bless
her I married up I was talking to her
about that ear I've heard you said on
air you did abely you're a handsome guy
but she's quite delayed she's fantastic
um in in Luke the El that discourse he's
actually talking about he's talking to
Gentiles right so Luke is rent to uh
written to Gentiles and so this is
Christians after the time of Christ
leading up to 70 AD and he's talking
about this and he says don't waste any
time when you see the armies around
Jerusalem flee the city don't even go
back down and get your coat leave and
get out of the city that was the fall of
of Jerusalem and 78 when the city was
burned and Lally Christ said that he
said before this generation passes not
one stone will be there 38 years later
that's pretty much exactly the same time
that they were wandering the desert as
well before they came into the promised
land so it's a very interesting quote
the generation had not passed but people
are like well wait a minute the ol it
discourse in Luke sounds very similar to
the olette discourse in Matthew and so
they get confused Matthew is written to
Jews Matthew's whole thing was writing
to the Jews and it was talking about two
different times Jesus at one time was
talking to the public during the day and
the other time he was kind of having
secret briefing meetings with his
disciples at night and so that's why
there's some confusion about whether
that actually already happened and we're
in a millennium or that there is no
Millennial Kingdom that's just really
some kind of really it's it's it's it's
it's men looking at the same mountain
range from different angles pretty much
yeah you're looking at the story and
you're not taking into context who he's
writing to and also like very simple
things that said and before these things
the stuff will happen and after these
things these things will happen it's
like wait a minute one says before
before and goes down this entire list
the other says after and goes down this
other way that's a different
conversation but we've kind of looped
those things together and it's caused a
lot of confusion all you really need to
know is there is a tribulation there is
a millennial Kingdom the Bible
definitely discusses it I don't
allegorize it I tend to take the Bible
more seriously and the more that I do
that the more that I see scripture being
fulfilled well it says that women will
become men men will become women your
children will be set up over you it
descri me it's all it's like insane like
none of that ever went on now it's a
like when this is being written people
read this is the crazy ever happened and
then it's they're like you guys are
crazy come on really guys becoming women
that's just crazy there's some
effeminate men but let's not go too far
so one of the other dividing lines is
you know when in that period of time the
church is actually taken out is it
before that seven years start is it at
the midpoint so before the bad time
starts is it at the very end because
Christians don't get to be exempt from
the kind of I guess persecution that
they've experienced it says the the
Beast will wage war against the Saints
and overcome them so you want to speak
against the because to me it says Christ
comes back the Archangel bounds Satan
and then the dead in Christ are raised
and then and then and then and that's
the tribulation to me to me it happens
at the at the at the end of the battle
of Armageddon I mean it seems to me like
a 10-year-old could do that but but so
many Christians who believe in Christ
and love God are holding on to that I
don't want to run them away I don't want
to say you're going to hell I don't want
to preach at you hey if that's what you
believe that's fine but then you're not
going to be ready for what's already
going down right so your your
responsibility is the same same as a
Believer or as somebody who's maybe
interested in what you know I guess the
Bible has to say about how the world is
going to go because looking around
you're probably thinking my goodness
things are not necessarily getting
better they're getting worse I tend to
come down on a pre-tribulation kind of
viewpoint right and so let me explain
why um I don't if you understand what
the tribulation is about right if you
understand what those last three and a
half years are it is God's final chance
for the Jews the Jews that rejected
Christ he said I will return to my place
until they acknowledge their offense and
then I will come to them this is God
fulfilling Prophecy from Daniel it's the
70th week of Daniel that talks about
this very specifically and not only
predicts when Messiah will come but also
predicts this period of time that will
be unlike any other time worse than the
Holocaust right that's exactly what the
Bible is describing because if you look
at some of the numbers that it talks
about for how many people will be killed
it is far far far worse but this is the
last chance of a loving father saying
I'm giving you one final opportunity and
I'm going to do some things I'm going to
tell you that I'm going to do them so
think of plagues of Egypt right I'm I'm
just going to start ratcheting up the
pressure until finally you let go and
understand that I am God and you are not
so that's one of the that's right God
repeats the same it's like over and over
again pattern so to the Jewish mind
pattern is prophecy so the Bible is so
much pattern developed and kind of laid
down the entire Book of Joshua
essentially is pattern for the end times
think about this in Joshua you know when
they're talking about the the city of
Jericho and the battle there and they
March around the walls and then they
scream and the walls fall down all the
kids know that from like Bible stories
when you're when you're a young kid the
part of it that we don't talk a whole
lot about is this two witness part they
send in two spies they don't get any
actionable Military Intelligence because
there is no battle plan that includes
going in and doing anything it's just
walking around the city you don't have
to have any intel for that right the
only thing that really happens is that
Rahab a harlot and her family get saved
she's Gentile so two witnesses go in two
witnesses at the Wailing Wall Gentiles
get saved Gentiles get saved it's a
pattern that God is do Christ later
exactly so it just lays down this
pattern throughout scripture so the next
thing that makes me believe that if you
look at Revelation 3 it talks about the
letters to the seven churches and it
actually starts in Chapter 2 but in
chapter 3 it comes to the Church of
Philadelphia a lot of people will make a
big deal about how these churches
actually represent kind of church ages
so to speak like an apostate church or a
Missionary church or an evangelical
church or a lukewarm church right so you
can look at all of these and kind of
study that that's a really interesting
thing to do the Church of Philadelphia
it actually says and I'll quote it here
in just a little bit it actually says
that if you hold on I will keep you I
will remove you from the time of trouble
that's very interesting so it's
shadowing the pattern of a potential hey
it's possible that there's a Rapture
here's the important part I want to say
interrupt the important part I I hope
you I hope it's pre and I know right I
am praying that it's free as well trust
me if you've read Revelation I don't
want to be around for the last 3 and a
half years of the seven year I don't
want to be around for the first part of
it because there's going to be this guy
coming on the stage that everybody who's
a Christian if you're still around
you're going to know that's the
Antichrist things are about to get
really bad and it's not going to be a
fun time to be around like and he's
going to be healing people and miracles
and in the last the yeah politically
he's going to come to power first and
it's going to be just this sweeping
thing can you imagine somebody from like
Romania or pick you know pick some
country over in kind of Eastern Europe
can you imagine somebody coming to power
right now in the entire world just
bowing down to the person and saying
absolutely yes this person what is it
the Antichrist you studied more than I
have what is what he what's the devil
able to do to make people go into this
delusion and worship this guy so it's
it's a time of trouble right so that's
what we need historically we've seen
that with the rise of Hitler with all of
these different kind of dictator
depression a virus exactly something
like that so this time of trouble where
people are looking and willing to give
up freedom for security we've been
willing to do that throughout history so
the Devil comes up with a solution yep
there's a person who comes in and has
the solution
can bring World Peace can unite people
that you never thought could unite and
really what marks the beginning of this
is the signing of a treaty with Israel
and so Israel signs a treaty with all of
its neighbors to have peace it's a
seven-year treaty and that's where that
seven-year tribul kind of scary when
Trump was getting that done I know right
when he moved the uh the embassy uh but
that was that was fantastic but there
was no there was no peace treaty with
the neighbors who no it was good but he
was doing but I'm just saying it was
still kind like whoa what happening no
but it's part of it right and so Russia
plays kind of a key role in this too in
the battle of Armageddon or MOG and AOG
what were the ones Russia go and Magog
Gog and Magog it's Russia and its allies
that typically people believe that are
the the armies that come down and invade
but really the seven-year treaty is what
kicks it off so if you're looking for
the start of this either you won't be
here and and maybe we were correct in
thinking that the church would be pulled
out or you'll see a treaty signed and
you'll be here but only for the good
part or you'll be here for all of it
either way doesn't change what you do
none of that matters this isn't
something that you debate we a lot of
times you know you talk about different
doctrines and people are like I don't
know if you have to be baptized to be
saved and I go you know what I don't
know either thief on the cross wasn't
baptized you know what I do know Christ
said to get baptized that's all I need
to know I don't know what it does I I'm
going to do communion I'm going to get
baptized I'm going to do well I mean but
here's the thing like I don't have to
know if that's salvific right if it's
going to be a part of the Salvation plan
I don't know I just know what Christ
said to do here he says to be ready you
can't know the hour and the day but you
can know the season Jesus actually holds
people responsible and accountable for
not knowing the time of his coming
that's what he was crying exactly you
don't know the exact time but you know
the season exactly right and so the Book
of Revelation is actually God the Father
revealing the plan to God the son Jesus
telling John on the aisle of Patmos so
many people don't catch that in the
first couple of verses this is the
Revelation to Jesus from God right it
says that right in the start at the very
start and we read right over it and go
okay well this is just the Revelation to
John No John is there as a witness to
record now he has a problem because he's
seeing stuff that he has no idea how to
describe but at the same time he's doing
his best when he says that you've got
something that spew sulfur out of its
mouth and it's got the power to sting
you in its tail okay what does that
sound like modern times right spewing
sulfur out of its mouth okay people have
conjectured maybe that's a tank okay
that sounds right soldiers behind it
could be the tail because they have
weapons and they can sting for the tail
okay if you're John and you have you
know horses and Buggies how do you Des
mountains of it's hard to describe these
kinds of things in a way that will make
sense and so John had a problem he had
to describe these things in a way that
hopefully people would be able to
understand but again the point isn't was
he talking about tanks that's really
irrelevant the point is there's a time
of trouble the likes of which the world
has never known World War I people
thought was the end of the world they
actually thought it was called the war
to end all war exactly except it was the
war to start another War right it was
insane and people thought oh my gosh
with World War II
this really does have to be the end it
is going to get way worse than that
that's what scripture think about world
at least 25 million Russians 22 million
Germans died oh and a lot of 600,000
Americans M you know I mean it was but
the point was we were we were on the
tail end of it I mean the Russians and
Germans killing each other we waited as
long as we possibly could because trench
warfare didn't sound like it was going
anywhere and it didn't we were smart in
said we put our troops that's why the
Army Air Corp was so big in big big
machines dropping bombs that seem
smarter it was insane but people thought
the world was going to end and people
thought that the Antichrist should be on
the stage and ready to go but it's just
going to get worse and that's not to
scare you the Bible even says there are
many antichrists there's models of it
well there has to be because Satan
doesn't know when the end is going to
come anyway so he has to be prepared
pretty much in every not omnipresent no
he has to be prepared pretty much in
every generation to have an antichrist
and this is this is conjecture so I'll
be hold this Loosely but theoretically
that means that Hitler could have been
the Antichrist if the timing was right
exactly the spirit was ready to do it
right I'm not saying gaban was the
Antichrist but I'm with you let's go
talk about this talk about Patrick
baitman or whatever he just to me my
holy you know the spirit me I look at
Nome and I go that's the devil I mean
like my gut just goes whoa not just his
actions evil There's real evil there and
I'm not saying he's the devil but he's
probably like a there's whatever's
running him is like a I mean like
Lieutenant to Satan yeah exactly we'll
get into a little bit about spiritual
warfare but I think that is 100% spot on
that there are people that are
influenced very very very heavily by
evil and scripture talks a lot about
that so speaking of scripture I just
want to we've mentioned the Book of
Daniel I just want to read a real quick
quote here and uh we'll throw it up on
the on on the screen and post we don't
have it right now so we won't be able to
see it Alex but I'll read it to you sure
So Daniel 9:24 this this is the 70 weeks
of Daniel so 70 weeks are decreed about
your people in your Holy City to finish
the transgression to put an end to sin
and to atone for iniquity to bring in
Everlasting righteousness and seal both
the vision and prophit and to anoint the
most holy place okay that's does it
sound like that has happened has sin
been put to an end no okay so 70 weeks
so we are not at the end of that 70E
period yet or some of those things would
have happened some of those things might
be able to happen in the first 69 and
then there's a pause and then there's
the 70th week of Daniel which is what it
gets into no therefore and understand
and this is this is the prediction to
the day of when Jesus would come and
present himself as Messiah that so many
people Miss know therefore and
understand that from the going out of
the word to restore and rebuild
Jerusalem to coming of the anointed one
a prince which this Messiah there shall
be seven weeks then from then for 62
weeks it shall be built again with
squares and mo but in a troubled time
and so that's talking about when they're
building the city when they're
rebuilding Jerusalem you're actually
going to have to build with one hand and
have a sword in the other hand and I
believe they talk about that a little
bit in Nehemiah right so art arz Xerxes
lanus actually gives the decree for them
to go and rebuild the city and they do
so that's the beginning of the clock and
there's some really cool studies again
Chuck mler does a great study on this to
kind of go okay here's the day because
we have good records on when that was
now how long is this weeks of years kind
of period that they talk about and he'll
go into a study on that we're not going
to get into that now does it come down
to right around now no it's talking
about when Christ would come the first
time oh yeah so there's something oh
like the Old Testament precursor the
same way right so this is Daniel saying
look Messiah is going to come at some
point got to get some Agway here yeah I
I'll rat you out as she's coming in very
secretly and doing a great job my
apologies so Messiah is is prophesied is
coming here right and so the Jews are
looking for the coming of Messiah
because he's going to deliver them and
everything's going to be great and
they're not going to be overtaken by
anybody they're not going to be having
all the problems that they are right now
especially when Jesus actually does come
they're being ruled by terrible people
with the Romans and they they they
really were looking for their deliverer
to come and it's really interesting I
was talking to my wife earlier about
this today we a lot of times don't
understand what Jesus is doing because
he'll heal somebody and he'll say don't
say anything don't say who did it don't
don't do anything with this keep quiet
be secret like he does that over and
over and over again when his mom comes
to him at the wedding of kaaa one of my
favorite Miracles cuz I'm a wine guy and
says I'm going to I want you to take
care of this problem woman my time is
not yet come like I'm not supposed to do
some of these things yet like it's not
yet so Jesus constantly pushes back on
this and he's holding back on his power
and then there's one time where he
demands it and commands it and that's on
the triumphal entry on the day that
Jesus looks out over the city and weeps
over Jerusalem and said if you had only
known the time of your deliverance
basically holding them accountable for
understanding The Book of Daniel and
saying you didn't know that I was coming
and this is not going to go well I wish
that wasn't the case and how can they
not deny it now when Jesus came and
warned him and everything he said now
came true absolutely I me it's
ridiculous it is and he actually said
some people came up to him some of the
leaders the spiritual leaders and said
make sure tell your people not to do
what they're doing right now cuz they're
saying hosanna hosana hosana in the
highest blessed is he who comes in the
name of the Lord tell them not to do
that
and Jesus looks at them and says look if
they don't do it the rocks will cry out
and do it creation will declare who I am
because today's the day and you should
have been ready for that right so Jesus
is that what he wrote it on the donkey
yeah it's an incredible talking about
that and I know they get mad about this
we love them to death how and a lot of
them are coming to Christ how can they
get mad when the Messiah told them and
then it all came true I mean it's like
but Jes like God knew this as well God
knew that they would miss this God you
mentioned it earlier when people were
you I think you were talking about them
praying in public and making these
eloquent prayers and then you've got
this sinner over there who said have
mercy on me God I am a sinner that's the
heart that he wants not somebody praying
in public for public recognition repat
King David really was sorry and prayed
in private absolutely well he prayed in
private but he he wasn't making a big
show of things if he did something in
public like he danced before God without
his tunic on like he had pants on by
probably no shirt he danced before God
there was nothing wrong with that
because it was genuine what what God had
a problem with what Jesus God in in
human form had a problem with was fake
belief fake sincerity fake piety people
who said one thing did another thing and
then actually lorded it over kind of the
the lady the the people right and said
hey you guys have to do all of these
things because of God and I am God's
Minister but I'm I'm cheating I'm doing
all these things that I shouldn't be
doing uh but don't worry about that
that's why he called them whitewash
tombs well Geral if you if you had a
national which you have with with with
you're great stream with Crowder if you
had a national TV show preaching every
week I'd tune in you're good you're
smart man well thank you very much I
appreciate it but no I would that's what
we're doing right now I guess I'm I'm
kind of chicken the egg for the Holy
Spirit to say something because you know
I mean chicken of the egg we are talking
to Millions right now so well yeah
absolutely no and so and then it goes on
and talks about um a covenant that is
made for one week and this is where the
week kind of weeks of year thing comes
in um in in in judism like there's you
can have a week of years right so it's
it's kind of something that's foreign to
us we say a week we mean seven days you
can actually have that mean seven years
right so it's just kind of a figure of
speech and so Daniel kind of gives that
to us in verse 27 he make a strong
Covenant with many for one week and for
half of the week so the first half so
that you don't miss it by the way the
Book of Revelation says it three
different ways and it says 300 I can't
remember the number of days it's like
12200 and something days three and a
half years and it gives you the months
it does months weeks years multiple
times to make sure that you understand
it's a three and a half year period it's
360 day years though which is very
interesting to me somebody can do some
research on that I think there's a
really interesting book out there but I
think called When Worlds Collide that
talks about potentially how the calendar
can change around a little bit but
that's again that's but what do we say
to the average person who doesn't
believe in God but then really worships
the system what are they going to do as
this world government comes in that
surveils you with AI and you've got to
submit and follow everything it tells
you or it takes your right to have a job
or eat or live or travel and basically
kills you I mean that is you've got to
worship the Beast to get the mark of the
beast and so what do you think what is
we know the devil is the Antichrist but
what is the Beast system Gerald in your
view and then what is it we have to do
to get this Mark cuz like you said you
don't get it by accident so how do you
refuse it you so you'll know that the
good thing is that you will know nobody
will ever accidentally take the mark of
the beast and that was a question that a
lot of people had like look with RFID
tags with uh I don't know pull out your
phone like if you live in China
basically you take out your phone and it
scans it and that's how you buy stuff
that's how you see if you're qualified
to get on an airplane or a train or get
a car loan maybe go to college uh if
you're ESG score essentially social buy
or sell without social credit score but
none I mean it it's all kind of one
thing I think we've talked about the ESG
stuff as well all of that is the same
thing so people thought oh am I
accidentally doing that people thought
barcodes because the dividers were sixes
and it said 666 I'm like look it's not
barcodes just because you go to the
store and you buy some cheese doesn't
mean that you've taken the mark of the
beast it will be a bowing down to a
world system think of the story of
Nebuchadnezzar and Shadrach Meshach and
abedo there was a big statue over there
they bowed down before it and worshiped
it worshiped it multiple times a day and
they stood up and said we're not going
to do it right that's what you'll have
the opportunity to do it won't happen by
accident but the way the mechanisms for
that to be carried out are being put in
place right now and that's what's
incredible you read Revelation and
you're like how do they do it you
worship it you got to submit and then
you get the Mark it's not like you just
agree to take it you have to worship it
and do whatever it says they have all
these patents where you're watched by Ai
and Lifetime and you follow its orders
completely or it's taken away from you
so you become a robot and turn your free
will over and become an extension of
antichrist right I mean and so God's
like yeah you've cut yourself off when I
made you and gave you all this
creativity and all this freedom and free
will if you merge with this basically
marry the devil and put the ring on your
finger of this Mark then then that's it
you're done yeah well and they talk
about the once you take the mark of the
beast you're right you can't come back
from that there is no coming back and so
if I I believe in a Rapture that takes
Christians out which leaves a pretty
terrible World in my my opin just back
up for a second though but that means
god you like the like you know you've
got the people on the cross and one of
them don't believe the other does that
guy you'll be with me in Paradise but
think about it what is it you got to do
that's so bad in the process that to get
that Mark to get that sign you've done
you've done the ultimate sin or you've
done something so bad God says it's not
just that you took it it's like to get
that marks to me is what did it yeah so
this is really this is the final chance
I think it's just the final straw kind
of thing like this is you declaring
sides you've picked your side kind of at
the last put eny uniform on exactly
right and right now we have Grace we
have the the covering of Christ and and
praise God for it because there are days
where and it's going to be rough you may
like maybe your children have sided with
Antichrist God forbid I mean there's
going to be a moment where you're like
my family did it I'm taking it fine I
about down well then you it's just no
you've got to say sorry I mean it it
absolutely you you have to and you're it
will cost you your life like you won't
be able to buy or sell means you can't
eat like maybe people will set up co-ops
there's a really cool series of books
called Left Behind by Tim Le and Jerry
Jenkins that I read when I was in high
school I started reading them and they
came out over I guess the course of
maybe 10 or 15 years they wrote a ton of
them really really interesting stuff but
it describes okay well you know think of
the Practical things that could happen
somebody can set up a co-op and have
Believers around the world there's some
kind of a system where they're trying to
kind of help people be fed and help
people get moved out of cities that are
I guess locking down by the way the UN
and and and and the Rockefeller
Foundation 10 years ago put out ploplis
and they said we're going to put the
people that won't take our chips and
accept our system in these ghettos yeah
and it said they're going to have like
it describes that so even the enemy sees
the same perspective it's it's weird
yeah absolutely and and so many people
think that it's impossible for that
system I want to go back to this because
this really is the test case this is
absolutely the test case so we've talked
about how covid-19 mirrored how maybe
the a world government could take over
because we need it because because it's
so bad it's going to kill everybody it's
not going to kill everybody right it's
so bad it's going to kill everybody that
everybody has to do this take it one
step
further it's not just that the situation
is dire and that we need to take these
drastic economic measures and freedom
kind of restricting measures it's that
people who speak out against it are
worthy of death how many celebrities did
we see tweeting F you if you don't have
the vaccine and you come freed yeah
exactly Arnold schz if you don't have
the vaccine and you come to the hospital
you should die and somebody else should
be taking care of they weren't
resuscitating people with heart attacks
in the United States cu the hospital was
too full and it wasn't exactly none of
these hospitals were too full we've
talked about this like that is the kind
of mentality people will have you are
now an enemy not just an enemy
ideologically not just somebody that I
need to make sure doesn't run for office
and win but somebody who should not have
a job a way to provide for their family
a place to live or even and that's why
China's the model so from from your
research the Bible because you've done a
better job than I have I always remember
in the in in Sunday school and stuff
they're going to be Guillotines chopping
Christians heads off I mean what does
the bible actually say about that versus
what people made up 100% true so if you
don't have the mark of the beast if you
refuse to worship the uh punishment of
choice is separating you from your head
which is typically
fatal a lot better than going to hell
supposed to be a joke out
no yeah you're right it is it's so
serious that a lot of people think okay
well what other world religion right now
because it will come in under a world
religion don't don't don't be fooled
don't think that they're going to say
God is not real that's not what they're
going to say they're going to say yes
God is real but God is this right
they'll say you can still be Christian
but you're not real you must accept
every other religion we have to accept
all of these other things what religion
right now kills apostates by cutting off
their heads Islam Islam absolutely what
regions are we talking about when we
talk about some of the places that this
all is going to happen Middle East
Middle East do you think it's get any
surprise that that probably plays a
prominent role I have no idea and Islam
didn't exist for 400 years after the
Revelation it was I think Islam came
around in what the 600s rough 500 600
years 500 600 yeah something like that
this was this was something this guy was
I I didn't I didn't even plan on getting
to Islam but this a topic that I've
studied a lot this guy was rejected by
the Jews he wanted to be Jewish but he
was rejected he was rejected by
Christians as well and then he kind of
dabbled in some Zoro asrian is yeah
exactly they're at the mecca or they're
at the crossroads of of of the of the of
the East West Trade he watched all this
absolutely and he kind of based
everything off of that what's really
interesting maybe we can do another one
on this so when we talk about esoy there
are players in this like there's the
Beast there is the Antichrist and and so
you've got kind of the false prophet
you've got all these kind of characters
at play in Christianity and we go okay
those are the bad guys the Messiah
coming back so Jesus coming back that's
the good guy if you study Islamic
eschatology they have this the same cast
of characters except the roles are
reversed all of the bad guys for them
are the good guys and our good guy
actually becomes a prophet for them
Jesus is a prophet that actually comes
and allows Muhammad to take Center Stage
it is absolutely mind-blowing when you
dive into it so like they believe this
stuff too there's an eschatology to
their game as well there's an end times
like the 12th imom one of my favorite
authors jela Rosenberg they believe
starting nuclear war brings G exactly it
has to be so bad now think about that if
they think to bring back their kind of
world order that they want their their
their Messiah essentially they have to
make the world so bad I just described
to you a scenario where the world is
going to get so bad that somebody coming
to power it's going to be very easy for
us to hand over our freedom and our
Liberty because they'll make the world
better and we need somebody to do that
these things line up they think that
they have to do that we don't we just
know that it will happen that's the
mechanis wild sit there and come out
with the amazing stuff that's in the the
Torah and then they're waiting for it
and then when it finally comes it
changes the whole world and empowers all
these
societies creates the Renaissance and
everything we have and they just go nope
we're not accepting that so here's why
here's why the Jews missed it so in the
book of Isaiah um there's some
prophecies that talk about Jesus right
so there's some very clearly Messianic
prophecies um that they Overlook Israel
was expecting a conquering King because
in Scripture it says says that the
Messiah will be a conquering King that
seems reasonable right what they didn't
understand is that they missed that he
would first be a suffering servant that
there are two times that the Messiah
comes they were looking for the second
time he came the first time and did this
and Jesus even quoted this and and and I
I'll butcher the quote if I do it but
it's when he stands up and the scroll is
unre unraveled and he reads kind of a
thing from Isaiah and he stops and where
he stopped was actually a point where
it's I think it's talk talking about
setting captives free I think don't
quote me on this I could be just getting
this a slight bit off and he stops kind
of at a comma so to speak the comma
didn't exist we inserted that but he
stopped right there and right after that
it's referring to the second time when
it's talking about judgment and
destruction and thank God he stopped
because if he had come back the first
time with condemnation for Sinners
people who had completely rejected God
none of us would have had a chance we
wouldn't have been born in the first
place but people would not even had a
chance but he stopped right there and
the Jews missed it because they saw
present condition
suck Rome occupies us we don't even and
how are you going to get a messiah that
fixes everything if everybody doesn't go
under it yeah I mean it's like the
Messiah comes everybody's got to follow
it everybody has to and so that's why
they missed it and so when it's hard for
them to come back to it but here's one
of the other things that I'll tell you
kind of kind of a wrapping up Point as
to why this all matters just a little
bit more one of the things that people
get I guess confused about is all of the
language of Revelation well Revelation 1
through3 is very clear very easy to
understand understand it's letters to
churches it's some admonitions it's
actually really interesting The Book of
Revelation is the only book in the Bible
with the audacity to say as chuck mler
would say read me I'm special because it
basically promises a blessing to those
who read and understand it's the only
book of the Bible that does that so it's
a very important thing to remember read
that book there is a blessing to people
who read that book first three chapters
pretty easy you get to chapter four The
Language
changes all of a sudden you start to
hear things that are very Jewish very
very Jewish they start to tell stories
that you don't really understand and
you're like oh my gosh I don't really
understand what they're talking about
with with the moon and the stars and the
Sun and this lady and this beast and I
is really strange if you understand your
Old Testament that gets very clear very
quickly that is why the church has
messed up so much on the Book of
Revelation because the church doesn't
spend a lot of time teaching you the Old
Testament and giving you a verse by
verse by verse understanding of what
well Christ said he came to fulfill the
Old Testament not to override it exactly
he's like I came to fulfill all of the
law not to get rid of it every single
thing that has been said in scripture
will be fulfilled but all of it is
written of Christ the WR the things that
were written a four time were for your
benefit the Old Testament is very
important if you understand your Old
Testament you will understand the Book
of Revelation much much better and you
won't fall victim I you have to know the
old test to know to know the you do but
most people think about this when you're
a Christian I mean growing up in the 90s
I was a Christian I was in church and I
read mostly the New Testament I really
wasn't studying the Old Testament until
I got into my 20s and went to Ministry
school and I was like I just can't get
enough of this like this is explaining
so much because we already did to make
sense we did it before it's all the same
stuff we did again right exactly it's
just repeating the prophecy is pattern
thing like there are some things that
will just blow your mind in scripture
where you're like I had no idea that
when when Moses lifted up a snake on a
brass snake and people looked upon it
they were healed of the afflictions and
Christ refers to that and says just like
when Moses lifted up the serpent in the
desert the son of man will be lifted up
and he who looks upon me will be healed
it it was a pattern that he was laying
down in scripture but most people missed
that because they never read the first
story in the first the pattern's key cuz
it connects it all together
energetically spirally and you see the
patterns being fulfilled right God using
patterns to kind of set prophecy and
those things being fulfilled so it's
very important to understand the Old
Testament so I'd highly encourage you to
do that if you want to study the Book of
Revelation there's a lot of great people
out there that you can look at I highly
recommend Chuck mistler just because I
think he's the right kind of teacher
he's humble he'll talk to you about
stuff that's interesting but he'll say
it's conjecture not to hold on to that
too tightly but he'll also tell you
verse by verse by verse and Link you
back to the Old Testament every single
time if there's one thing about what
Chuck M did he died in 2018 but he was
just a phenomenal teacher um he would
take I think 30 hours to go through the
Book of Revelation and kind of walk you
through all of this because he's going
back to the Old Testament so much to
kind of show you okay this is what it's
talking about here's what this is
talking about what's incredible
is what I'm seeing the Great Awakening
happening the third great Christian
Awakening wening that we've had in the
last 300 years is is it's not that the
church is even teaching this when it
should be because this is the reality
people are hungry for it it it's that
people are out in the world and seeing
yeah the Satanism and the occultism and
the devil worship and the the the
destruction and the attack on God the
attack on family I mean it really is
satanic and so if people think it's bad
now it's going to get crazier and
crazier and crazier yeah and so that's
why people I think really need to
understand that we're on a planet in
space we were given free will God really
did make us there really is this outside
force you know there's all the new agers
say it's space aliens or whatever mean
what is the devil it's an
interdimensional creature stranded here
with an army that wants to control us
well why is because we're made in the
image of God and look what we imagine
what we're able to build now we're like
babies still oh yeah the technology the
things we've done is nothing because we
are actually more advanced than God's
angels and then this is my lay person
I'm give you a take but I mean we are
made in the image of God we have eternal
spirits and God made other things before
and decided to make us later and these
things are jealous of us and want to
kill us and want to get rid of us I mean
it's really the Demonic forces yeah
absolutely talk you know what we'll talk
about spiritual warfare in one second
here I I think we'll we'll make that
into another episode because I think
that'll be really we should do a lot of
episodes I do them well you know I think
we'll do that in a minute because that
that's really important but look to
Alex's Point like that we're held
responsible as a Believer as a non
whoever it is it doesn't matter you're
held responsible for the information
that you have access to and right now
you have access to God saying hey you
won't know the day and the hour that's
fine don't worry about that know the
season we're in the season whether that
season is going to take a long time to
fulfill I'm not the guy saying hey in in
two years and five years and 10 years
I'm just saying that you need to be
prepared because that's what God tells
you to do not because I am saying that
not because I'm trying to sell you some
emergency supply kit or make you a great
prepper I'm just saying it is good for
you to be ready it's also good for you
to know the end of the story we win we
overcome this through Christ thank God
literally because the world is a very
terrible place it's very sad when you
have movies coming up about human
trafficking and that's just one fraction
of the debauchery that is on this planet
the things that we do to each other make
God cry and it all comes to an end wipes
away every single tear from every single
eye and you don't have to worry about
that anymore evil is finally dealt with
and Justice and I think that's something
really important to say here I know
we're taping this today so when you put
it in post maybe you can add AOC and Al
Gore and Betto saying the world ends in
2030 they mean they're artificially
collapsing things to consolidate power
and depopulate but but but really it's
you've all know Harari and Bill Gates
them saying the future is not Human by
2047 there'll be no humans you must
merge the machines or we'll get rid of
you they're the ones saying it's the end
of the world they are they are literally
fulfilling prophecy I remember my
grandfather would say the devil can't
help it he must follow God's plan he
will fulfill the prophecy and that's the
thing is they think we're the ones
saying into the world no we're trying to
keep the gas pipelines going we're
trying to keep the nitrogen going we're
trying to keep the farming going we're
trying to stop Wars stabilize the third
world we're not like oh we want the end
of the world let's drink Kool-Aid it's
the left and the globalist that are
fulfilling it to bring the crisis and
then they can stop the crisis because
they're running it with their Antichrist
yeah absolutely I I love that you talk
about that because a lot of times you
know we we live in kind of a world where
we're talking politics and we're talking
kind of what's going on culturally and
um and obviously there is an
intersection of Faith to that but
sometimes it's hard to kind of break
away from that and talk mostly about
faith and what's going on now this this
is interesting because the first time
that we talked we mentioned some demonic
warfare spiritual warfare topics and I
said we're going to wait and actually
talk about that this is something that
we'll cross over very cleanly into
what's going on today with some of the
characters on the uh I don't know on the
left um that are basically in some way
shape or form controlled manipulated
influenced by demonic forces and we'll
get into some specifics on that but um
recently I I don't remember how long ago
exactly it was but it was it was an
interesting find that Fox News was
actually going to uh match donations
even if it went to um some really crazy
things including uh some people who were
Satan worshippers yes that's that's a
really interesting thing to have the and
look I'm not taking a steaming pile on
uh on Fox though sometimes I think it's
definitely warranted but when they do
stupid stuff you should definitely call
people out and that is a stupid thing we
don't need anybody supporting satanists
that that should that should be an easy
one I think and I have not supported
Satanist but I'll go ahead and tell the
story and I'm not attacking the person
that was my lawyer I've had probably 20
lawyers in all the lawfare attacks I've
been under over the years and one of the
lawyers law that's a good way of putting
it that that did some filings for me is
a big first amend lawyer and has
represented the ACLU and farmers and
Native Americans and hundreds of groups
and then later I learned they had
represented uh it's not church is Satan
it's called something else the point is
it's that big National group that like
puts the Satan things in front of cour
houses yeah uh with like the bath and
stuff it'll pop my head in a minute look
it
up people said oh my God your lawyer
represents these people well I mean I
agree with their first amendment but I
don't agree with their ideas that's just
one lawyer I use no that's that's who I
who I do not use once I basically
discovered that only because I don't
want that intersection and that was not
a choice I made but with the fox thing
it's very clear what they're doing and
with like the you know the governor of
of Illinois promoting chopping up kids
and all
this when people get confronted with
something they're doing that's wrong or
an association that's wrong I think they
should have a chance to say hey I didn't
know and that's why I'm here benefit the
doubt right they should be given the
benefit of the doubt and the opportunity
to go hey I didn't know that well you
never think when you hire lawyer that
they representing the and I get his
argument is hey everybody gets Free
Speech okay whatever you just don't know
when you like oh yeah I'll hire this
lawyer to file this thing and they're
like hey you know your lawyer represents
the what's it called it's going to pop
my head in a minute uh Temple of Satan
or something like that it's just it's a
satanic Church uh that is really all you
need to know about it but it does I
agree with you 100% there is no guilt by
association with that but it's good to
kind of go okay well maybe I maybe I
don't want that I'm say on the fox
subject you get to where you know on
that one it's notation guilt by policy
absolutely yeah they went with it like
with Trump he poses in photos with
Epstein you know a decade before all
this stuff happen so he wasn't exactly
the frequent flyer that Bill Clinton was
on that so satanic temple satanic temple
there we
go well look it spiritual warfare is
very real it's referenced in scripture
in a number of different places but
Ephesians is one of those places that a
lot of people go to so Ephesians 6:12
for we wrestled not against flesh and
blood but against principalities Powers
against the rulers of the darkness of
this world against spiritual wickedness
in high places that means powerful read
that again you probably should have
started the whole show with that read
that again slowly this is key so
Ephesians 6:12 for we wrestle not
against flesh and blood but against
principalities against Powers against
the rulers of the darkness of this world
against spiritual wickedness in high
places so the Earth is Satan's right now
he doesn't have possession of it forever
because Christ comes back with the deed
there's something in Revelation that we
didn't talk about where it's written on
the outside and inside and that's
typically a kind of like a title
contract um that says Jesus comes down
and says basically this is mine give it
back um but right now this is Satan's
domain for now we're behind we're Behind
Enemy Lines yes we absolutely are we're
behind the curtain with all this stuff
and so we have to be very careful but
you have to understand that this is a
very real thing and to the Jewish mind
when these guys are writing to them we
have these kind of new converts to the
way which is Christianity kind of in the
first century this is they're very
Jewish minded still culturally
everything they they understand that and
so when they're looking at this they
know all these things because in the Old
Testament it's full of it now some
people have made the argument that some
of the things that they talk about of
demon possession in the Old Testament
was really like maybe schizophrenia or
somebody with a mental illness I don't
think that that is exactly the same
thing that it's referring to here
because God could have been very
particular about that he could have said
that this person had a mental issue but
let's just leave some room for that and
know that not every one of them is like
that and I'll give you an example of why
I know that 2 Kings 616 and 17 this is
one of my favorite parts of spiritual
warfare to understand what's going on
because it helps you understand that
this battle isn't what most people think
it is most people think it's just demons
flying around influencing people and
that's a very scary thought to have 2
Kings 616- 17 and he answered so this is
Elisha his let me just set the stage
Elisha is causing problems for some
ruling people around the area and he's
thwarting some of their military plans
okay these guys find out about it and
they come with their army to kill Elisha
his Prophet walks outside sees these
guys up on the hillside freaks out a
little bit understandably so runs back
in and tells Elisha and here's what he
says and he answered fear not for they
that be with us are more than they that
be with them and Elisha prayed and said
Lord I pray thee open his eyes that he
may see and the Lord opened the eyes of
the young man and he saw and behold the
mountain was full of horses and Chariots
of Fire around Elisha this is not a fair
fight we WI
God opened the eyes of this guy and
immediately he saw the mountain covered
with the angels of the Lord's host right
the army of God there to defend Elijah
and Elijah had insight into this this
young man who was serving him did not
and he was able to lift the veil and let
him see it he prayed to God and said God
will you will you open his eyes so that
he can not worry so that he is not
afraid so that he can see the fighting
that is going on this isn't just a bunch
of bad people showing up this isn't just
a bunch of De demons attacking us we've
got an army behind us that's bigger than
theirs we're going to be fine and in my
experience sneaking to Bohemian Grove
and covering skull and bones and which
still freaks me out by the way that you
snuck into Bohemian Grove that's crazy
they could have killed you but but but
the issue is you when you know when
God's with you you feel this big force
behind you yeah and you have to go yeah
right you have to go and you but it's a
it's beyond confidence it's like I it's
not a power trip it's y it's like wow
I'm like this is like I'm in a river
this is this is Unstoppable I I'm
thinking about bring tears in my eyes
it's powerful when you realize you've
got all these angels with you it's it's
big well and it talks about this
heavenly host and this cloud of
witnesses in the New Testament like this
is this is a topic that you would not
have had any trouble talking with
somebody about at the time of Christ or
or shortly after when these books are
being written because people understood
this now today we look at it as a cult
or we look at it as a scary movie or
maybe it's Poltergeist or maybe it's you
know something that you see around
Halloween and we think oh yeah it's this
dead people whatever I don't know if
Spirits are real but a lot of people are
willing to believe in some form of
spiritual things that are happening but
more and more people that don't have God
but are but if you fight evil but you
don't have Christ people are getting
demonically attacked yes very prominent
people and I can't say names but I think
how dumb the devil is like if I didn't
believe in God and now a demon attacks
me I'm going to go to Christ but a lot
of people get scared like what do I do
demon what do I do but it's definitely
going on well and a lot of people think
that demonic warfare is going to
manifest by some coffin opening and
something rising up out of the coffin
with cob on it like a lot of times just
people being mean to you lying about you
manipulation manipulation I got to tell
you the strongest thing I ever saw was
about six years ago my my my youngest
daughter was only about six months old
and my wife who went to
uh Washington State University there in
Seattle wanted to go see some of our old
friends so we go for five days so I go
I'm going to go out on the street and I
was literally attacked everywhere
there's video people ding coffee on me
all this but it was like i' go around
corners and it was like they would they
were talking like demon some of on video
they would finish the sentences and I
was like and you could feel like it was
a domain like the Bible says like that
was under its control like a satanic 5G
or something and I was just like and
like my camera guy who normally is
fearless he goes I can't come out with
you anymore we're
not it'll freak you out he he was seeing
it yeah and it was like and it was like
they were boiling out of businesses and
stuff to attack us and they like knew
they weren't even watching it online was
like there was some kind of like satanic
bandwidth or communication system and so
when you're in a city totally controlled
by the devil which is happening to San
Francisco Seattle these places are
Fallen there's feces needles everywhere
and like mentally ill people everywhere
and and and it's it's like it's
spreading it's spreading it's it's a
weapon so for those of you who think oh
come on Alex you're you're you're being
a little kind of out there on this stuff
Daniel Daniel had some pretty good
insight into this and most people miss
it so Daniel 103 this is Daniel praying
for 21 days and getting a vision from
God right who's that's delivered by an
Angel but listen to how he describes
this the angel describes this uh this is
the Angel talking to Daniel in verse 13
but the prince of the kingdom of Persia
with stod me 21 days and behold Michael
one of the chief princes came to help me
for I had been left alone there with the
kings of Persia this is an angel talking
that when you started praying 21 days
ago Daniel the word went out from God
for me to come to you and this demonic
stronghold withheld me for 21 days until
I called Michael the Archangel who is
known for battle and War Gabriel is
known for being the messenger Michael
had to come and take care of this power
which is not going to be a contest at
all and then I was able to get to you
he's basically cluing you into there's
more going on here than you think but
here's where it gets really interesting
in verse 20 he goes and then he said do
you know why I've come to you read this
last part is is the part that just gives
me chills and now I must return to fight
with the Prince of Persia and when I
have gone forth indeed the prince of
Greece will come he's talking about
these ruling demonic forces in these
places not an actual person the
principality of the air they have office
over the region exactly so when you talk
about going to an area in Seattle and
all of a sudden you're in some kind of
domain where it seems like this area is
in some way different and it's this
demonically controlled place that's what
Daniel's talking about right here this
is what the angel is telling
like you're walking down the street and
guy goes we're going to get you f you
we're going to get you in the same voice
you're around a corner that's right we
told you we're going to get you and
you're like whoa something like they
it's like it's synced up either no more
mushrooms or this is really I wasn't on
mushrooms no I'm just kidding yeah
that's what I'm saying you get you no
but that's that's what people would say
like oh he's out of his mind he's doing
drugs he's got a mental ill that's why
I've got more of these things that have
happened I don't even tell them because
they'll do that but I mean this is
totally sober this has happened and it's
like really weird it's 100% true Michael
Zimmer was a great guy a good Christian
guy he was like I I got to stay in the
Hotel this is too demonic he go I can't
do this no absolutely it was like they
were running out of buildings at us and
just like we so I had a a sort of
similar experience except it was in
similar in that I knew that I was in
like enemy territory so I went to
Cambodia and I was working with a
missions organization and the first time
we went over there it's it was about
teaching we went out of the villages and
we taught people and showed the Jesus
video and there was like 100 people that
came to Christ it was amazing and so I
worked with them and I came back after a
month and we went back because we found
out that human trafficking was a huge
problem in Cambodia second worst place
in the world for it next to Thailand and
so we we discovered that at the end of
our trip and so I'm on the board of this
missions organization me and a couple of
guys and so I go back there to to kind
of help set up something to help fight
human trafficking right because people
can get out of human trafficking but
then they fall right back into it
because they have no idea how to make a
living well one of the things that we
did while we were there was we went to
the local dump because that's where a
lot of children unfortunately live in
the dump and they're looking for scrap
metal and things like that and so
Ministry Partners set up there and so I
started seeing some kids playing with a
a ball down the alley and I went down
there and started playing volleyball
with them just playing with them just
because I wanted to interact it was not
part of I wasn't set up to do anything I
was just like oh I'm going to go over
there and interact with these kids and
we walked a little further and someone
ran down the alley to one of the people
that was Cambodian that was with us and
said hey you have to leave and this
person looked at me and then the person
from Cambodia who we were with looked at
me and said they're saying we need to go
and I looked at their face and
immediately I felt it I was like there
is something demonic here and
immediately we left like we got on our
horse and got out of there and that was
just like that moment where you feel it
like you said like you could just feel
it we then went from there over to um uh
now I'm forgetting the name of the place
that we went but one of the the the
biggest the island of Sumatra in
Indonesia largest Islamic country in the
world it's not in the Middle East most
people don't realize that it's the
largest Islamic country in the world the
entire time we were there we felt that
like you feel this demonic oppression
and it is it is absolutely that's when
people get back to America K the ground
and we're the best house in a bad
neighborhood we're far from perfect
folks but people that haven't traveled
the world they don't know how oppressive
you can feel it yeah absolutely and so
we when we talk about spiritual warfare
we talk about you know things that maybe
are influences or these principalities
or these powers and I mentioned earlier
when we started that this is Satan's
domain well there's a a verse in
Revelation uh in verse I'm sorry in
chapter 12: 7-9 and it talks about war
breaking out Heaven it says Michael and
his angels fought against the dragon so
that's Satan um and the dragon and his
angels fought back most people don't
realize like the Angels they weren't you
know like these machines they basically
had some kind of agency some kind of
free will to be able to make a choice
because they fight against God which is
silly but a third of the angels are
actually thrown out and I'll tell that
in a minute but he was not strong enough
and they lost their place in heaven the
Great Dragon was hurled down that
ancient serpent called the devil and
Satan who leads the whole world astray
he was hurled to Earth and his angels
with him and in Revelation talks about
woe to the inhabitants of the Earth
because his time is short he knows his
time is short and you guys are going to
have to deal with a Fallout this is his
world a third of the Angels Came Down
with him those are the demons and he is
the God of this world players yes yeah
he has the rights to do what he wants to
some degree in this world now there are
limitations to that thank God right
otherwise no flesh would survive so
thank God for for that being held off a
little bit but it's not just okay so
Satan's here there's these
principalities what about guys like
Gavin Newsome I think that's what we
mentioned earlier in the other show we
did where we talked about people that
are demonic influence I think you
mentioned well I mean when you I mean
when I think you look at any
AOC uh Biden they're completely taking
over with
Nome their influence they're also taking
over it's just I mean I anybody can see
it but if you have any discernment you
look at Nome it's like when you look
at you look at Bill Clinton you look at
Hillary looks like a big clown demon
I'd say she's about 90% level as bad as
Nome but my spirit tells me Nome is
about the most evil thing I've ever seen
walking around right I mean that's like
my the Holy Spirit tells me that's
really bad right there like right and so
don't think of evil as coming and and
being somebody who's committing murder
right that is an evil act so but what
I'm saying is it may not be that obvious
right for us said he's collapsing the
most important state ining the whole
country right you start to see that but
as conservatives we see it because it's
a very obvious thing we're like oh my
gosh as a Conservative Christian I look
at Gavin Newsome and I see what his
policies are and I'm absolutely repulsed
by it so that's a very easy thing for me
to see but if you're somebody maybe who
is a Democrat you may look at it be like
oh well you just disagree with him
that's not what we're talking about like
these kinds of people demonic influence
if you will CS Lewis wrote a book called
the screw tape letters which is
basically it's incredible right it's
basically this correspondence between
demons kind of a a newer de trying to
figure out how to get this young figh
pilot to not come to God and and of
course they lose in the end EX exactly
but it's tactics it's like well have you
tried this have you tried this have you
have you tried to make work so important
that he neglects his family and so that
his family disintegrates and his kids
hate him and his wife hates him and so
he'll run away from God because he'll
blame God like it's all of these
different things that the demon is
trying to do to influence and so when we
talk about crazy is it's real it's like
Avatar they're right there in right
Beyond light vision and and now the
funny thing is none of the globalists
are atheists now if you look at the
quantum mechanics and the physicists now
they all know Dark Matters five stronger
they all call it a simulation but it's
just God holding this together I mean
they know this is not all there is we we
we see a very limited spectrum and there
are these things that want to destroy us
absolutely and the battle is real and if
you are not prepared no flesh is going
to be saved right and and it's not like
we're up here playing Dungeons and
Dragons for liberals to tune in because
I know our general audience gets this
but to the average trendy oh these guys
just have this fiction book from
thousands of years ago and they're
trying to make it real and they have
this
normaly bias and they're just they're
just confirming everything no The Whole
World's being built like it said it
would be the whole thing's happening and
humans are going out of their way to
screw themselves and screw others and
hurt children and saying they do it for
the devil and I've looked at it it it's
real and there's this Army that is out
to keep us from doing what we're about
to do because God said the eye hasn't
seen the ear is not here no one knows
what God's gotten store for us yeah so
we've got some big mission that we're
not supposed to do people get mad at God
and say well why did God do this you
know the Satanist always says well God's
just say us why did God do this no God
gave us Free Will and gave us a choice
because God loves us and then God even
gave us a cheat sheet so people need to
know folks just believe in Christ know
the devil's real pray to God get pray
for Christ to protect you and I'm and
everything will open up and your
problems will literally not go away but
be you'll see God in your life and
you'll see it push back you'll see the
beginning of Victory and I'll tell you
I've always been a Christian but it's in
the last 10 years or so that I really
starty promoting Jesus Jesus every day
that the enemy came after me people say
well then you shouldn't do that no I
should do that but I'm telling you they
don't like it folks they know it's
powerful they I mean like nothing is
even 10% close to it like you say Jesus
Christ to the devil to his demons the
things I know prominent household names
that were being attacked viciously by
basically demons and they didn't know
why they didn't believe in God but they
were doing things devil didn't like as
soon as it's and they went to Mystics
they went to Jewish leaders and said oh
you know what do I wear this cabala
bracel let say these prayers didn't help
him and they got told pray to Jesus and
when these things attack say in the name
of Jesus you are commanded to leave and
it gone now look it it what that's the
name they can't handle folks
everything's about the fruits the proof
like you that hydrogen bomb it blows up
you say Jesus it blows up there's
nothing like it they it's real okay
right Christ has the deed went to hell
got the keys but can't free the Earth
Until We join him and as soon as we do
that it's game over yeah yeah there
there is no stronger name right there's
no name under Heaven given a man that
that can absolutely carry the power of
Jesus's name but as somebody who maybe
is not a Believer like if you're not on
that team you you are susceptible to
some of these things a little bit more
than maybe a Believer would be I don't
say that to scare you I say that to
caution you don't play around with these
things because no amount of you saying
no as a non-believer and not not
invoking your will cannot stand against
Satan no absolutely not do me a favor
get that to your head do me a favor I
feel so this is something that a lot of
you need to hear Satan is blamed for a
lot of things that he didn't do when you
do stuff
that's exactly you have to take some
personal responsibility so don't look at
this as the boogeyman situation where
it's like well he did it right no but
there is some very real stuff that is
going on in the world right now that
there is a spiritual battle that is
taking place this is not just one side
on the left versus one side on the right
and they have different ideas and it's
not even really about politics because
at the end of the day none of this I I'm
a
monarchist by definition I am a
monarchist I am wanting God to come and
rule in reign that's my monarchist it
doesn't mean that I don't love my
country I do it doesn't mean that I
don't want America to thrive I do but I
understand that it is a bigger game than
just what we have here and we need to be
prepared for it so fight for here it's
very important but understand that
there's another battle going on and you
have to be prepared for it and you
understand their tactics a little bit
better when you look at something thing
like this and Alex I mean I didn't pay
much attention to politics in the 90s I
I really didn't like I was doing my
thing I I kind of knew some stuff I I
didn't really care a whole lot about a
bunch of different topics that were
going on so I didn't pay much attention
but the the homosexual agenda that was
being pushed on people was something
that did cross my radar because it was
being talked about a little in churches
and it was really being pushed on my
generation and and so a lot of people
out there we have people that watch this
show that that would you know say that
they are gay or lesbian or whatever
right and that would be that's fine I
I'm not saying that you should uh that
you should do that I think the Bible
does call that sin you have to address
that if you have a problem with that you
have to take it up with God and not me
but I do love you as a person just like
I love every sinner out there in the
world but there's what's attached to it
exactly I never would have thought that
we would go the steps that we've gone to
but those steps well what about
pedophilia what about this trans thing
what about all of these other issues
exactly as soon as we said hey we don't
hate you we with you but it opened the
gate up to just and they said no no no
that's a straw man come on you're just
making up an argument that's not real
this thing isn't going to happen that no
one wants to sterilize your children no
I remember the really smart hardcore
Christians who I even kind of poo pooed
because I'm like look gay people
whatever I love God but whatever you
know I'm not OBS why are you obsessing
on that but then they were right they
were said once that first Domino Falls
speciality pedophilia and it's all true
and and we're living in a day where it's
like we look back and we're like gosh we
were more right than we thought yeah you
know like oh Christians were dead on
yeah what's crazy is the Christians of
the ' 80s and 90s I wish they were here
now because they were superstars of
reality and now maybe they're censored
or I don't know but I don't really I
know they're there but I don't see like
Christians should be doing a big Victory
lap like everything we said's coming
true we always say Hey you know Elon
must said we need more conspiracy
theories they all came true or what
conspiracies
didn't people say oh Jones Alex Jones is
pred I I knew most this because was in
the Bible I had no idea the frogs were
being turned gay I thought you were just
kidding that was just me reading some
report but it actually we read a story
the other day we're like well son of a
gun yeah I just saw that in report too
so they just used me out of context they
knew it was true they used me making a
joke about it to then make I know it was
a joke but it was like I took a joke
because you're you can't even joke and
not be right Alex that's that's the
problem with all this stuff we can't
even make it up anymore because it keeps
coming true and we're like all right
well they won't certainly they won't go
so listen for people that aren't
Christian and don't like the cosmology
of God and his machines these angels
that have free will and
us there's a bunch of Dimensions we're
on a planet there's all sorts of stuff
swarming around in space we're under
attack and this message is kill yourself
humans are bad murder yourself and by
the way we love Satan and we want to
rape kids I mean the the people running
things are bad well that stuff's not
Justa it's celebrated it's celebrated
that's the thing it's celebrated there's
more human trafficking going on right
now than any other time in human history
it's huge it's it is one of the most and
I'm not when I say human trafficking I'm
not talking about like a 20-year-old
woman that's that's horrific that is as
bad as it needs to be there is another
level of kids there are people on this
planet that pay money to have sex with
children and it is not being met with
the kind of thing I think Donald Trump's
response if you're in human traffic
death penalty that's the kind of
response you should have to evil at that
level but there is a group of people on
this planet that is pushing the agenda
of hey let's normalize pedophilia let's
normalize these kinds of Love Is Love
okay so there's no restrictions on that
no matter how old they are and again if
we put up with that if we'll let them
have sex with kids folks There's No
Limit I mean think think that's the
final thing if we won't protect our
children God is going to turn his back
on us well some of the most severe
people look at the uh the the the
Canaanite Genesis side I think is what
they call it in scripture where when
when they come back exactly you read my
mind because that Society what they
would do is they had a god called Molech
and he had hands on him they would put
fire underneath that and Heat this the
metal hands up to where they were
glowing hot and then put live children
on them to sacrifice to that God think
about that they'd barbecue their babies
exactly and we think about that
abstractly God saw it as his children
and he wiped that out he wiped that out
of Canan so when you want to talk about
wi he told the Israelites I'm giving you
an order kill these people get rid of
every single man woman and child and you
look at that and you're like oh my gosh
how do you deal with that you need to
understand what was happening there and
that sounds really really really harsh
and I listen it is but God sees sin and
he didn't want that infection spreading
to the rest of the world because that
would have meant more death more
destruction and you need to understand
that like that's what's happening today
you know what we're doing we're not
necessarily heating up the The Altar and
placing a child on it but we are uh
throwing this child on the altar of
medical intervention to change their sex
when they're seven years old which is a
form of human sacrifice to take their
fertility yeah I mean think about what
you're doing to that person you're well
here's the thing people that have
abortions that don't know that it's a
child can repent and say they're sorry
later yeah but the how I could do like
10 hours on liberals glorious time yeah
I killed that little son of a it
is a human and I killed him and I like
it and women going I get pregnant just
to kill them I know so when Tok videos
celebrating that
they're I forgot the name again Church
of Satan what are they called uh Temple
satanic temple satanic temple they have
filed in Texas and a bunch of States
they just got denied by like the Supreme
Court saying no when we kill babies it's
a ritual they said it's our first
amendment under our religion to kill
babies really yeah they came out un and
they just got
overturned I know that doesn't listeners
I know that doesn't sound real
I I bet the crew can pull it up right
now typ pin uh it's one of those other
things that's G to come out and be like
yeah he was 100 Temple of
Satan uh says
abortion part of First Amendment ritual
and you can p oh you know what I bet I
bet yes and probably in response to roie
Wade yeah probably trying to say like no
that's part of our first it just got
overturned by federal pills Court my
point is is that they're admitting it's
a Sacrament and let me tell you
something I've gone out and protested
for 30 years at abortion clinics even
before I got on a I was doing that and
you think okay I'm going to go Santa 100
feet away like you're supposed in her
federal law and hold the sign up they
the doctors come out you've seen the
videos I'm going to kill him I love the
devil and and Weirdos show up and like
black Mercedes and hold stuff up in
front of you and yell at you and spit on
you and we're getting those kids you
won't stop us and then and there's
hundreds of videos thousands of videos
you go to the Texas state house when
they're trying to pass these laws and
there's women like in suits going I love
Satan devil to kill you Satan and you
think oh they're just doing that to
shock us no they're coming under this
yeah because this is the murder of
children this is the Satan's like
paycheck man this is like this is their
thing I me remember Schumer that time
never shows em motion about two years
ago goes you get rid of roll you have
summon a h we're going to get you those
babies I mean it was just like that is
their Quarry that is the lion over the
baby yeah well I mean it's 60 what 60
million plus Americans have been k or
something yeah it's an incredible number
but again we look back and Alex what
what I said about Molech most people
probably recoiled a little bit most I
mean people may have actually gasped
they somebody may have cried from
hearing that what about 60 million kids
killed in the womb like what about
Federal documents which I heard about 20
years ago that confirmed the last three
years in lawsuits by by lifesight others
where it says the university wants the
once the fetus delivered heart
beating they're delivering babies to
these facilities I know it doesn't sound
real for harvesting for harvesting yeah
it does I mean unfortunately it does but
look that's the debauchery that we're
living under so to say that you know you
I think you made the comment I can't
remember if it was on this show or the
last show where we basically said like
we're the best house in a bad
neighborhood we still got some really
big problems in our house and it's this
is not just people being misled I don't
want you to think that because if you
think it's just people being misled then
you're not going to no no most of them
like it now well that's the thing 20
years ago most liberals were still nice
people misguided who thought they were
the good guys I go to their events I
cover them so do
you I mean I'd say half of them are
demon possessed now and
another 340% of what's left is crazed
and maybe 10% still deceived I mean they
are foaming at the mouth so when I act
all crazy and do that there's videos of
all that I'm just doing imitations yeah
I'm a good you know imitator that they
are I mean they are they are nut they
are devil worshipers they absolutely are
and they're being controlled by that but
that it's a bigger picture so you can
fight all you want and like I said you
should you should fight I'm so glad
Donald Trump's Legacy if it is nothing
else is the Supreme Court that is his
legacy did a great job there he he did a
ph and that's Trump's biggest problem is
he was like me until about five years
ago myself five years ago he thought he
could beat it himself I know people
behind the scenes that know him he
really knows God now he's praying every
day he's really that's why they're so
scared but I mean I and I've always
loved Christ but I still thought till
about 5 years ago I can it was still me
like I'm going to beat him and I got
this will and the strength a pride and I
really realized God's like no you have
you're actually powerless it's all me
and it actually takes a weight off you
but you still fight but you just go no I
I don't have to prove anything I'm just
going to have to do what God says well
you know what go where God tells you to
go do what God tells you to do let the
Holy Spirit speak through you let God
get these victories because ultimately
what you want is change ultimately what
we wanted was roie Wade struck down now
it's not perfect because it does leave
it to the states I think that's the best
way to do it I just want the states to
do the right thing that's why it's not
perfect because some states are
celebrating it and saying hey we'll pay
for you to have your employees come here
and get the abortion still right but
we've got a culture of death this is a
spiritual battle this is a spiritual
battle that we've been fighting since we
were created we've constantly been lied
to and told that we can be God and yet
we go out and act like Satan all the
time humans left to their own devices do
not get better that's not how we operate
we're very selfish beings and so if you
think that Humanity's answer is just for
everybody to get out of the way and that
religion needs to leave us alone and
that we can all just kind of be our own
Gods and we're going to get better we're
going to love one another you've not
studied history well let me just say
this to people what you're saying Gerald
is so on target folks I know a lot of
new viewers because I care about the
regular viewers that are awake and we
love you and you're the reason the
show's here and you support it but the
mission is to reach the new
people the devil real God's real this
energy is real and people out there that
feel alone and don't know why things
don't make sense just give it a try
reach out to God and say are you real
show me in my spirit because our God is
the real God it doesn't rape you doesn't
take over your free will like Satan does
you've got to really ask God to come
knock at your door just pray to God
tonight start praying every morning
every night say I want to be good I want
to know the future I want to know what's
happening I want to know your vision for
me and and I'm open and show me and God
is going to show you and and you may
have committed a lot of really bad acts
God May touch your heart and say you
need to repent of that cuz God has to
open the channel up and get the
repenting going where we can really beam
you the information because you got to
reject what you've done wrong and then
kick that trash out the door but I'm
telling you God is so real and is just
waiting to take your hand please take
God's hand yeah absolutely and he he
wants what's best for you life is not
found in the way that the world wants
you to live it's not and and and you
know what the Andrew Tates of the world
with the the video you know the webcam
stuff that he did that was not where
life was found having all the money all
the cards and notice that was used to
then hurting bad exactly that's not
where life is found there life is not
found in Fame it's not found in Fortune
it's not found in having every single
pleasure that you can possibly imagine
people have tried and you may be able to
reach certain people I'm not putting
Andrew down but here's my Bugatti and
here I am and I'm you know it's like
yeah you're getting a bunch of like
people that are lost are are like like
we can all sit show off some wealth what
does that do the wealth is is God the
wealth is Humanity the wealth is our
future the wealth is our Consciousness
it's all his and can go away in a moment
right and so there is a spiritual battle
that is going on you need to understand
it you don't need to be afraid but you
need to understand that it is real and
that it's happening all around right now
like the scriptures that I read just
told you it was that stuff didn't stop
and go away just because we're 2,000
years past the we've just forgotten the
truth for sure we've forgotten it and
we've honestly what we've done is we've
we've made it into a holiday we've made
spiritual warfare into a holiday we like
Halloween we get to celebrate ghost look
at how the Jews were this tiny little
group were able to defeat all their
enemies and all stuff cuz they figured
this out we calling in the angels and
the minute they didn't the minute they
went against God's plan they started
losing the battles and they literally
changed real time real time and won
following God's plan looking up in the
Old Testament and some of these battles
are like all right we're going to go do
our own thing nope you're going to lose
okay we're going to change and do God's
say wow we won with only 300 people
that's incredible they and and you can
say well that's a story no I've
experienced where I literally just go
God I can't do it help me and like it
changes like boom yeah and I'm already
in line with God I'm already but I'm you
got to really just go I know you're
going to do it please tell me yeah
exactly of course you can't be some
prayer like give me a $10 million or
give me a me that's not a genie it has
to be in line with God's will yeah it
does but if if you ask God to do
something that's in line with God's will
it's going to happen yeah so look if
you're if you're somebody who has never
prayed to God before like Alex said just
pray and say God look I don't understand
this just have a genuine conversation
God I I think you're real I think I need
a savior because I know certainly that
left to my own device is that I'm going
to do really terrible things because
I've done really terrible things in the
past maybe I'm better than my friend
across the street but I'm still not good
because ultimately I believe that you
alone are good so can you just help me
understand this can you help me
understand what it means to pray what it
means to be saved what it means to
understand that Christ died for my sins
what it means that you knew all of this
was going to happen and you valued Free
Will so much that you sacrificed your
own son who had never been apart from
you in ways that we can't even
comprehend on a cross and you knew it
was going to take that to make sure that
I had the opportunity today to get down
on my knees sit on my bed stand here
wherever I have time and pray to you you
did all of that just so that I would
have this opportunity today and just see
what happens guys and if you have
questions about it if you need some
guidance on where to go to find a church
or anything like that just shoot us an
email uh you can do it at tips
louderwithcrowder.com we'll make sure
that we check that maybe we'll set up
another email for it later but look this
is an opportunity there's a battle going
on it's happening all around you you're
probably affected buy it more than you
know but I guarantee you the country
that you are in is fighting at tooth and
nail right now and we're not always
winning and we need to so thanks very
much guys Alex thanks for being with me
I really do appreciate it that has been
Gerald apologizes apologetics great
job Gerald apologizes apologetics it
doesn't mean that